your first contact at nuki you can just
see it nibbling away at the edge there
what's happening the edge of the moon
they're just cutting across just
starting to cut in to the face of the
Sun a very slight mark a slight curve
there and actually in these pictures we
can see it's very slightly rugged as
well very nice sharp view there so
you're seeing the moon's rugged surface
it's mountainous and valleys surface
right on the edge there it's starting to
cut into the face of the Sun that will
just begin to grow and cut more and more
of the Sun away you were telling us
we're getting a triple whammy aren't we
today because yes we've got the Eclipse
we've also got the the equinox the the
spring equinox and the super moon that's
right and so we've got a super moon as
super moon occurs when the moon is
within a sort of the 10% closest point
that it can reach in its orbit around
the Earth it is an elliptical orbit that
it makes it is the spring equinox today
astronomers say that's the first day of
spring so that's occurring today let me
tell you it doesn't really love the
first day of spring it doesn't feel like
it right here I can see lots of people
here perhaps not quite as prepared as
they want to be this morning it is a
chilly day and as you say the
temperatures will suffer a little bit
more as the Sun is that is going to
begin happening very soon local to us
here so yes a triple whammy a nice event
and incalculable odd figure out how
likely that was to occur again and gave
up the calculation of series one oh it's
very rare to have these three fall at
the same time